please welcome dr ken jong
[Applause]
please sit
i'm sorry i danced too much no no you
did not that was only 40 minutes long i
know i just
i mean well that's what i do you know
i'm just kind of those moves were
described i mean first of all those
moves are quite fascinating and some of
them seem disgusting i know i do this
it's basically like four moves and i
beat them to death all right this is my
typical talk show entrance i come in you
got to do the michael jackson kick
i'll try to i don't want to kick the
michael jackson michael jackson kick
like that got it and then michael
jackson swivel yeah got a swivel and
then what are you doing
i'm sorry i thought you were throwing
candy sprinkles no
it's not it's candy store i'm saying it
i'm sorry it's candy sprinkles candy
sprinkles please it shows it shows the
danny sprinkles it shows that he's a
performer who's willing to give it all
yeah
thank you right thank you i i am one of
the most likable desperate comedic
actions
you know i really want to be like i want
to i want to be liked i'm annoying but i
know it you know what i mean that's just
that's like you like you we're both
annoying and we know it
what that's what we i didn't realize
a charming goofiness oh we're both
annoying and we love it
you know i mean we're educated you went
to harvard i went to duke
school yeah
i went to duke and i'm a doctor you know
he's not as smart as me whatever there's
no big deal
you know but that's you know we're
enlightened idiots we're enlightened
self-aware uh annoying i am not
self-aware i thought
i thought i was being really cool uh
all these years you just mentioned
you're a doctor yes sir this is true you
are a real md yeah
real md i know comedy killer here's
what's interesting uh who just did all
that out there
okay don't spell it i'm sorry
[Applause]
hey doc how did my test come back you're
gonna die
he dead
what the hell is that oh it's fun to
mock the asian right
i get it
or is that just a
device my question for you uh ken if i
can call you kendrick doctor dr john
would be but ken yeah uh dr john um do
you respond ever to real medical
emergencies i'm serious do people is
there ever
if there's a real medical emergency do
you ever intervene or
are you an actor now well you know you
know i am i am an actor now but like i
said like conan said i was a fully
licensed medical doctor practiced like
seven years and so i was on a i was on a
plane recently like two years ago and
this one person actually had vertigo and
and had some weakness and i was worried
that this was a stroke or a cardiac
event and the stewardess said is there a
doctor on the plane and i'm like well
you know i used to be a doctor and he
was like sit down ciao
[Applause]
exactly like that
really so you're trying to save a life
and they won't let you she won't let me
it's like if we yeah if we want to spit
take or we want to get a pie in the face
we'll let you know you know
but it it but in in real i did tell her
like you know i'm a physician and
actually took care of that person and
monitored that person's blood pressure
and just kind of checked for
neurological signs and just actually
monitored blood pressure throughout the
flight and and everything turned out
okay that person's fine and it really
happened it was good
and um good work it was good and
and afterwards and afterwards afterwards
a person's like you know
thank you so much for saving my life not
a fan but thank you
to say that he said to say not a fan i'm
not a fan but you'll do in a pinch
that's what he said
that's interesting he truly said that
why work that in at that point it's so
easy to just go thank you why did he
work in and he was worked up here's my
question did you dance for him maybe
yeah i kept saying i think you got a
stroke
can you move like this
[Applause]